- Y'all spent some time
in quarantine recreating
old movie posters, right?
With your kids, can we look at a few?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay, cool.
Here we go.
- Okay, so this is the original
poster of Audrey Hepburn
in "Breakfast at Tiffany's."
And I had this crazy idea that
we should duplicate famous
movie stills or posters with my kids.
I don't know why I thought of
that, but they liked the idea.
Okay yeah, there she is.
Okay, so that's Matea and that's
one of our rescue kittens.
That one is called
Creamy, orange creamsicle.
We've been rescuing
kittens during quarantine.
So I was doing her hair
and makeup and she,
at a certain point was like,
mommy, this is not perfect.
I cannot do this, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I cannot,
this is the best I could do.
I'm not a professional
hair and makeup artist.
- Let's see the next one, this is so cool.
Okay, this is the original, James Dean.
- Yeah. There's the original James Dean
in "Rebel Without a Cause."
And there's my son, Johnny,
my 14 year old rebel with,
or without a class.
And we actually showed them the movie
and Johnny really loved it.
So we had the red jacket, we had,
if you look at the, the actual poster,
it's really hard to see there,
but it does have a sort
of blue corrugated looking
background in it.
And we had this storage
container on the property.
So Johnny stood in front
of it and looked dreamy.
- I mean, your family is the
most gorgeous family ever.
The fact that they can
pull these posters off,
I wouldn't even attempt it.
Okay, here' "Giant," great film,
- Johnny's actually the
one who's responsible
for putting all the graphics on,
together with all the images that we took.
And Johnny's also an
awesome baseball player.
I just wanted to say that.
Holden, who's in "Giant," is also an
amazing baseball player and "Giant"
is another James Dean classic.
And it kind of fits with
Hodlie's sort of like,
well, I like to call Holden
my, my burnt marshmallow.
He's like hard and crispy on the outside
and soft and gooey on the inside.
He's an amazing, wonderful boy.
And they're all very artistic.
They love painting, drawing,
photography, anything to
do with all this stuff.
- Oh, I love, I love it.
And they all have their own
like individual personalities.
It's so crazy, even they grew
up in the same household.
It's it is so funny,
everybody's still so different.
Let's see the next one.
Oh, I love this one.
Dorothy, original.
- That's Lutia, she's eight years old.
She's holding another one
of our rescue kittens.
I think that's Hufflepuff.
Yeah. We also have a black,
sort of a black and
tan, Brindle, Frenchie,
which may or may have
looked more like Toto,
but we decided to use the kittens,
but I think they just all really loved
the dress-up aspect to this.